nice la parole est à monsieur vincent
ledoux merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la milice
l'éducation nationale madame la ministre
vous souvenez vous du jacadi auquel vous
jouiez certainement dans la cour de
récréation
vous savez ce jeu d'école dans lequel le
maître de jeu donne des consignes à
exécuter à partir du fameux mot au
déclencheur
jacadi pour tromper l'adversaire il
donne l'ordre sans le sésame ou bien il
redouble la syllabe en jacca 10 à 10
dans le nord depuis quelques mois
parents d'élèves directeurs d'école et
mer sont les joueurs aient perdu d'un
jeu qui serait bien sympathique s'il ne
mettait en péril l'organisation même de
nos fêtes d'écoles ainsi les consignes
relatives à l'organisation de ces fêtes
et kermesse au regard du plan vigipirate
tiennent du jacadi a dit sans vraiment
le dire
et si vous me suivez encore madame le
ministre chapeau car nous n'y comprenons
plus rien à vos règles du jeu ainsi on
demande aux parents d'élèves et
directeur d'école qui ne sont pas des
professionnels de sécurité d'assurer le
filtrage et le contrôle aux portes de
nos écoles
le contrôle visuel des sacs de vérifier
systématiquement l'identité des
personnes étrangères à l'établissement
on demande ainsi aux parents ce que la
police municipale n'a pas le droit de
faire par exemple dans les transports en
public un comble aujourd'hui on
m'informe que dans la ville de roncq
quelques directeurs transport mal est
fait
en prestation d'élèves sur le temps
scolaire sans publiquement avec un
nombre limité de parents alors madame la
ministre
quelles sont les raisons d'un tel
bricolage dans notre académie du nord
les parents ne comprennent pas qu'à
paris on tolère les nuits de boucan dans
le nord ont supprimé car metz d'école
vous l'empêchez rien de plus à sciences
po à paris 8
vous préférez vous y prendre aux fêtes
d'école allez vous enfin donner des
règles claires et précises sans faux
fuyants sans tentative d'évitement
car si la fête d'école tient du jeu son
organisation allait pas 1,8 jacadi a dit
et vous madame la ministre
qu'est ce que vous en dites
la parole est à madame najat vallaud
belkacem qui va vous dire si monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député vincent ledoux je
crois qu'en cette période chacun
comprendra bien que la question de la
sécurité des établissements scolaires
est une préoccupation sérieuse qui amène
en effet à prendre un certain nombre de
mesures alors je voudrais répondre très
précisément à votre question puisqu'elle
porte sur les kermesses et les fêtes de
fin d'année dans les écoles donc
concrètement je voudrais rappeler ici
que concernant les activités qui ont
lieu surtout du temps scolaire s'est
bien l'éducation nationale qui
responsables de leurs tenues ou pas de
leurs tenues ou de leur non tenues c'est
ainsi que nous pouvons être amenés par
exemple au lendemain des attentats de
novembre dernier à interrompre les
sorties scolaires ou les voyages
scolaires en raison des questions de
sécurité
tout cela étant à chaque fois des
mesures temporaires et donc je le dis à
tout le monde
aujourd'hui les sorties scolaires les
voyages scolaires ont lieu il n'ya pas
d'interruption s'agissant des activités
qui ont lieu hors du temps scolaire et
c'est le cas pour les fêtes d'école et
les kermesses la responsabilité relève
des communes des communes qui peuvent
considérer c'est le pouvoir
d'appréciation des mères qui peuvent
considérer que des raisons de sécurité
doivent conduire à ne pas tenir de tels
kermesse ou fête d'école mais je vais
vous répondre maintenant sur la question
des principes
je vous rappelle donc le droit sur la
question des principes je suis en ma
qualité de mise de l'éducation nationale
extrêmement attachés aux kermesses et
aux fêtes d'école car je trouve que cela
joue un rôle de sociabilité entre
l'école et les parents qui est
absolument indispensable donc les
instructions que je passe à toutes mes
équipes c'est de les maintenir le plus
possible qu'il y ait ici ou là et c'est
le cas visiblement dans le département
du nord
des mères qui est décidée malgré cela de
prendre des mesures de précaution
c'est regrettable et je leur dis qu'ils
peuvent se rapprocher de nos services
pour que nous puissions les aider si
besoin a renforcé la sécurité avec le
ministère de l'intérieur met à faire en
sorte que ces kermesses se tiennent
merci madame la ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance